sara is in San Francisco
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Sarah my
pleasure how can I help
okay so about two weeks ago and I my
husband and I we about $55,000 in debt
and I'm really excited to get started
one baby step two but my my dilemma is
announcing my husband and I rent renters
we've rented for the past seven years
and are the owner passed away and left
the house to her grandchildren so they
are selling the house and they want us
the bus to buy the house and the plan
was to buy the house even though we have
no down payment and we're in debt so bad
the way that we are but because we live
in Northern California where it's really
really expensive to live my husband
feels that the house is a good
investment because it is you know we're
getting we'd be getting it what he says
is under market value I don't really
know that that is a fact but he is super
handy so he feels like he'll be able to
fix up the house over the time that
we're looking in it so my question to
you is is it wise for us to to buy a
house I'm not sure we can afford and
slow slow the process of us getting out
of debt I mean we obviously have to live
somewhere or should we consider moving
and renting somewhere else or moving out
you know to a different location
entirely most financial questions have
at least two answers to them and one of
them feels good today but hurts you
long-term one of them feels bad today
but causes you to win long-term does
that make sense yeah and the people that
are wealthy do the one that feels bad
today because you to win long-term right
and that is you're moving
okay you can't afford this house you
know you can't afford this house you
told me three times in the conversation
you can't afford the house your husband
wants to fix it up he doesn't want to go
through the pain of moving he thinks he
might smell a deal but you guys are
broke you need to go rent something as
cheap as you can possibly rent increase
the length of your commute if you have
to and get your debts paid off and build
your emergency fund and then start
building towards a down payment
what's your household income take-home
monthly we take on their around $7,000 a
month yeah okay sure you might get about
110 120 running yeah that includes my
second job which how old are you okay so
you have to ask yourself what is the
what is the answer to this question that
causes the 50 year old version of me to
be smiling that the 37 year old version
of me was wise in other words if you may
if you go by this house and it chokes
you guys and you have to work a
part-time job and you stay broke from
now until 50 all because you bought this
house which is what the math is telling
me in this conversation when you're 50
you're going to be pissed at the 37 year
old version of you yeah and that's what
it is it's gonna put you in the it's
gonna put you in the rat and wheel mode
or you can't get ahead you can't get
traction because you can barely breathe
now or you wouldn't even be in this
situation I mean in like you guys went
on a Mediterranean cruise or something
that didn't what's going on here you're
just trying to make ends meet in the
freakin San Francisco Bay Area it's
tough you know you make good money but
you don't make you know you don't make
Silicon Valley money you know so you
know it's tough and three kids and that
market so can you pull it off and stay
in the general area yeah
but I'm gonna rent as cheaply as I
possibly can which obviously increases
the speed at which you clear the debt
and build your emergency fund and build
your down payment
then you buy a home in the home will be
a blessing I'm afraid this home is a
fixer-upper that you can't afford it
sounds like a double curse I can't
afford it I can't afford it B I need to
fix it up what's what you told me
and I'm going I'm going based on what
you told me
now if the house is worth eight hundred
thousand and they're gonna sell it to
you for three hundred thousand we might
have to have a discussion but that
didn't what I heard no I mean you know
my husband really feels that you know it
could be worth you know 150 200 thousand
dollars more than what we're going to
get for it down the road is now down the
road yes down the road is after he fixed
it up you're buying a fixer-upper what's
it worth today as is if they put it on
the market versus what they're selling
it to you for sounds to me like they're
selling until you market value but oh
yeah Oh after we fix it up and after we
wait three or four years and let you
know good California inflation real
estate kicked me kick the thing up then
it'll be worth $150,000 more well no
kidding of course it will be you know
but today it sounds like they're selling
it to you for what it's worth today and
it's as is condition no bargain I'm out
Tapout yep I'm sorry it's inconvenient
as crud to do the right thing I mean I
have a root canal then move and you know
telling you to move it's not I it's one
of the last things I tell people to do
but nothing you've described here said
stay I just you know I'm I'm concerned
because even to rent here is you know
gonna increase our expenses now buy and
because we got in a really good deal so
what we're paying now is really not a
lot but you'd yeah and get that way you
get the further out of town you get that
a lot or your rent drops unless you add
towards Napa Valley but I mean you know
they don't head into the Silicon Valley
either but you see what I'm saying
there's there's an inconvenient place to
live where the rent is cheaper this
whole thing is inconvenient but it is
the best five-year plan it is not the
best five month plan
the next five months are gonna suck
right so that the next five years don't
you live like no one else so that later
you can live and give like no one else
it's hard I get it I get it
hey thanks for the call